hey youtubers is Charlie and since we've
learned one of the first three Star Wars
spin-off movies is gonna be Boba Fett I
wanted to talk about what that movie
might look like it's not gonna be the
first spin-off they make so it will be a
while before we see it though but it's
totally possible that the bones of this
Dead Star Wars video game could kind of
provide the framework for what the movie
looks like it's called Star Wars 1313 so
this video is gonna be a breakdown of
that video game and why I think that it
would make a great starting point for
the Boba Fett movie I'm also gonna do a
production update on all the other
spin-offs too because we've actually
learned some new things if you're
finding me for the first time I'm gonna
be doing Star Wars bonus videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
normally I try to post them on Tuesdays
I've been out of town a little bit so
that's why you're seeing this video
today so production update on the
spin-offs first gareth edwards who
directed godzilla was just hired to
direct the first spin-off movie they
didn't announce the title but it is
dated for december 16th 2016 right now
the rumored sequels are han Solo Boba
Fett and red 5 as in an x-wing rebel
story I think that first spin-off movie
is actually gonna be red 5 because the
biggest names you know inside the Star
Wars offices are working on the biggest
movies and obviously Boba Fett and Han
Solo are much much bigger than an x-wing
movie that's Lawrence Kasdan and Simon
Kinberg they're probably working on the
bigger spin-offs and it seems only
natural that they would give the easier
story to do to the newer director that's
just my opinion though so we can talk
more about those other spin-offs in the
future but now let's talk about Boba
Fett for a long time I always thought he
was the coolest Star Wars character
darth vader was always the face of the
franchise but in the 90s before all the
big prequel and Disney stuff happened it
always felt like the most hardcore Star
Wars fans were always more interested in
talking about Boba Fett he was just way
more mysterious funny because everything
we know now about him comes from the
expanded universe in the prequels so
don't be surprised if Disney changes a
bunch of that stuff we can talk about
that in a sec but I think there's a
really good chance they could use that
Star Wars 1313 game that died as
inspiration for the look in the tone of
the movie you know from a visual
standpoint it's like a dark bar crime
drama set on Khorasan so in case you
never heard about the game LucasArts the
video game arm of Lucasfilm showed off
footage during e3 2012
an unnamed bounty hunter running through
the streets of Khorasan trying to chase
down a bounty what made the game
different was is that it did not feature
Jedi powers it was more like battlefront
and you had to use technology and
hand-to-hand combat later it was
revealed that the narrative of the game
was going to tell the story of Boba
Fett's early years as a bounty hunter
cut from thunderous applause to dead
silence
LucasArts was scrapped the company was
folded whenever Disney bought them out
and the game was completely shelved
Disney has announced no plans to
resurrect the game itself but from a
visual standpoint it's perfect for this
Boba Fett spin-off movie it addresses a
lot of the issues fan tab with the
prequels looking so bright and shiny I
always felt like the environments in the
prequels felt way too clean to be
threatening you know like you want to
feel like you can get hepatitis just
from touching the console I always loved
that steampunky look of the original
trilogy and this game took most of its
inspiration from that so cut to Episode
seven and JJ Abrams there is some new
evidence that they're actually kind of
going back to that original look from
the original trilogy if you saw the
video that JJ Abrams posted about
winning a chance to cameo in Star Wars 7
you could see a real-life puppet
creature right next to him that film is
also shooting on film stock not digital
like all the prequels so it seems like
these new Star Wars films including the
spin-offs are gonna look a lot more like
the original trilogy so the 1313 Boba
Fett game totally fits within that
ideology so it's not all totally perfect
though if you look at the concept art
for the game I do see a couple issues
first these are gonna be Disney movies
and even their darker stories have a
certain Disney fied look to them
tangible and real but very polished this
Boba Fett concept art is way darker and
dirtier so I don't think they're gonna
do exactly what you're seeing right here
and second Disney made it a point to say
that the writers were starting fresh
whenever they came to the story's so if
they did use this Boba Fett game as
inspiration a lot of the story would be
changed I don't think that's totally a
bad thing but we have to remember
concept art is exactly that just a
concept one really cool thing about the
game though is that Boba Fett was
supposed to have a droid companion that
was eventually going to double-cross him
which feels totally appropriate for a
Boba Fett story it kind of reminded me
of HK 47 from Knights
the Old Republic encoder HK was actually
built by reven to hunt down Jedi and the
rebels cartoon that's premiering this
fall is basically going to tell that
story the Empire's process of hunting
down the last of the Jedi after the
events of Return of the Jedi and a lot
of you have been asking me about that TV
show too and yes I will be doing weekly
videos whenever it starts airing they
said fall but I'm expecting October
there's gonna be 16 episodes total and
it's gonna air on Disney XD as for the
timing of the Star Wars movies they've
only announced the official release
dates for Episode seven and that first
spin-off but Hasbro did leak some
information based on the toy lines and
their release dates so here's the
breakdown of all that first there's the
rebels cartoon this fall in 2014 that's
confirmed
then there's Episode seven December 18
2015 also confirmed then we have that
first Star Wars spin-off on December 16
2016 confirmed unofficially that's
probably going to be the red 5 movie
then there's Episode 8 in 2017 probably
December release and keeping with their
theme next is the second spin-off movie
in 2018 which could either be Han Solo
or Boba Fett then episode 9 in 2019 and
then lastly the third spin-off in 2020
so take all those dates with a grain of
salt
movies get moved all the time but
generally what they're trying to do is
release a Star Wars movie every year but
episode 9 is so far off that that's
probably gonna get delayed at some point
they make so much money on them though
if they ever did run into big schedule
problems they probably would not
hesitate to throw money at the issue
just to get the movies out faster so I
hope you guys agree that this Star Wars
1313 game is great inspiration for the
Boba Fett's spin-off movie production
hasn't started yet and it's still a long
ways off so I'm not expecting to get any
official news about the movie for a long
time obviously I'm not expecting it to
be that first spin-off movie either but
now it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what do you think that
the Boba Fett movie should look like and
do you think that they should just scrap
all the prequel backstory and expanded
universe stuff and start fresh
so my next Star Wars bonus video is
probably going to be my top 10
characters I'd like to see in episode 7
be sure to subscribe to get it
and that might schedule is slowly
getting back to normal I should be able
to post that next Tuesday I'm also
seeing Maleficent tonight
so you can actually click here to get my
review for that I'll add the annotation
as soon as I post it and you can click
here to get my breakdown of the Star
Wars Episode 7 cast thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives